up on the hill it is a bit of a bullpen
day for the padres miguel diaz 26 years
old nearly 60 career big league
appearances almost all of them in relief
he gets to start today second baseman
jonathan india leads things off ground
ball up the middle and india continues
to get on base a lead off single for
india here is jesse winker this is lace
the opposite way in fair off with the
helmet india strolls across standing
jesse winker wasted no time putting the
reds in front one nothing winker in
scoring position for castianos
and he swings through some gas at 97.
out number one in the top of the first
one gone and now joey votto will come to
the plate
they appeal and he goes navado not too
pleased with it otto is not happy
[Applause]
wow and now david bell just got thrown
out of the game and ryan attitudes
hearing it in stereo bottom on one side
and david bell on the other this has
been a season for bottles showing a lot
more emotion than he has historically
and bell
is no stranger from getting run himself
now you've got the fans and the reds
players getting into it padres fan who
paid a pretty penny for that seat down
there has also been ejected david bell
by the way who i'm pretty sure had been
ejected during all of that had not yet
left the dugout so now reynolds the
second base umpire came down to tell him
hey by the way you've been tossed you
gotta go so now reynolds is starting a
new argument as if he's just now being
ejected for the first time and he wants
his money's worth this is really turning
into something and about as big of a
delay as we have seen in a long time
we're only two ounces into this ballgame
here's tyler naquin after all that
that skims over to machado with the
backhand
and it ends quickly vladimir gutierrez
25 years old a rookie out of cuba making
just his fifth career start he can't so
far you can see the numbers his first
four starts been pretty impressive
tommy fam leading up bam lines this boy
he ripped that all the way to the base
of the wall that's how we start this one
fam a stand-up double so fernando will
stand in with a runner on second nobody
out swing and a miss
good slider down and away and down on
strikes tatis one away that's a big out
but now he gets jake cronin worth
right back to the mound gutierrez knocks
it down some self-defense
is that number two moving fam to third
so manny coming up with fam on third two
out so machado walks that'll put runners
on the corners with two outs eric hosmer
coming up with an opportunity to do
damage padres down a run in the first
swing and a breaking ball lifted in the
air pretty well hit but it'll bring in
naquin to make the catch and the inning
is over i thought off the bat he hit it
pretty well but it turned into a pretty
easy catch for tyler naquin and now
tyler stevenson is aboard to begin the
reds second inning one away here's kyle
farmer this is into left field
barreled by farmer
stevenson pedals into third base fam
gets to it and now stevenson is being
waved in here's the throw cut and a
throw to third the tag safe reds lead it
two to nothing looks like suarez has
something in his eye clearly is farmer
blowing on his eye now that's that's
being a teammate this game couldn't get
any weirder joe musgrove with a pinch
hit bunt single puts two on two out for
tommy fam gutierrez brings it home the
pitch is popped into the air
shallow right field out goes the first
baseman here comes india and it's india
reaching over freeman to make the catch
as the two converge down the right field
line the play is made and the inning
comes to a close the left-hander daniel
camarena comes on to make his major
league debut from right here in san
diego cathedral catholic hitch is taken
strength recall daniel camarena a one
two three major league debut and he caps
it with a k tying around at the plate
nobody out in the bottom of the third
inning jake cronin worth kronenworth one
of the best velocity hitters in baseball
roped out to right field cronin turns on
it and gone
and just like that the game is tied the
swag chain makes its first appearance
today and the bags are packed for
machado since the start of last year ten
grand slams for the padres first pitch
swinging a laser fair into the corner
manny machado clears them up and gives
the friars the lead of the fourth inning
red's put the first two on base and
that's going to bring up center fielder
tyler naikland ground ball chopping it's
into left field past machado and tatis
not an easy thing to do and tatis does
not look good
it looked like fernando dove for that
ground ball base hit by nayquin and and
landed awkwardly on the left shoulder
which of course is a little bit of an
ongoing thing that we're all tracking
fernando tatis jr is indeed leaving this
ball game hopefully it is a very very
short term thing this go around for
fernando to load the bases for eugenio
suarez his mortgage is not due it's late
in the left field for a base hit we are
tied in the fifth once again in this
series the reds have rallied back and
the go-ahead run is aboard the bottom of
the seventh eric hosmer coming up hard
hit ground ball farmer has it the race
is on his second he steps on the bag and
it's on to first in time for the double
play go ahead and run aboard in the
eighth for the reds we'll bring up kyle
farmer farmer chopping this kim the new
shortstop whips it on the cronin worth
under first for the double play
tommy fam having himself a night his
third extra base hit
the bottom of the eighth with two outs
the padres have the go ahead right at
scoring position this feels a lot
different with hassan kim batting than
fernando tatis kim is hitting more tatis
after fernando tati's junior had to
leave the game with injury
the one-two
ball
and the padres take a 7-5 lead in the
bottom of the eighth
what a moment for hassan kim
a current call for hassan kim
and the gang of style dance
with tatisse injured and kim filling in
ha sung comes through
up on the mount one of the game's best
closers tucker barnhart pinch hitting
him up one away in the top of the night
here's jonathan india india
two for two off of melanson and that
brings a tie and run to the plate the
big bats coming up here's jesse winker
back up the middle kim a step on second
on the first who else to close it
out a son kim puts the final touches on
a padres win
they have guaranteed themselves a series
win they've won the first three against
cincinnati in dramatic fashion once
again